like there's a story in the film about
you went to a party and on one couch was
i think marlon brando james dean and was
it paul newman all newman yes and paul
and well paul became a great friend and
marlon became a friend not a great
friend but quite friendly he used to
come over to my house at my flat and
he would go and say anything to eat i
said yeah there's some stuff in the
fridge and he would go in and eat every
jar
of ice cream because i only had ice
cream in the fridge
and he would eat it all which is why he
got a little
but he wasn't
you know he's known as this great actor
but he he wasn't that keen on it no we
because i was totally impressed i mean
i'm 20 when i go to hollywood i think i
was very brave i got into a huge plane
went to new york had to stay overnight
change into another plane to go to la
and then i didn't know a single soul
there except a makeup man that i'd
worked with and um so i talked to marlon
brando terrifying but adored him
and i said well you know i when did you
get your love of acting he said i hate
nothing and he did an expletive and said
acting i said you hate it he said yeah i
just do it for the money i don't like it
he said it's just a lot of you know
stupid people dressing up and making
faces in front of the camera he was very
uh
but i mean he was such a great actor
yeah so um i did a few more cow towers
and you're so fabulous and how can you
do that but he was very down-to-earth
and then he
then he went upstairs with my sister
jackie who was only 18.
yes i know
that story that story took a turn
i'm just i'm just so glad she was 18.
[Music]
you